good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
home day
it's the best day of the week you guys
except for friday and thursday
um saturday and sunday yeah but it's
someday so hump someone you love
get into the groove and before you know
it we're on the other side of the week
yeah we're gonna get you over the hump
today so so exciting we actually have a
great show for you today because
i mean we say that like it's a surprise
honestly every show is a great show we
always have a great show and we say that
like we know what's gonna happen like
sometimes the most mundane mindless show
becomes our best yet
and days where we think we're gonna kill
it like it's just a standard good show
okay so my theory that today's show is
gonna be a great show
is based on a few things one fast five
really good stuff really strong strong
stuff you'd love to see it
two tv recap we have it's full it's full
we have real housewives of new york and
we have love island i've caught up
completely even though you described the
sunday night's two hour episodes
for me i felt like i needed to watch it
and i'm glad that i did because i
definitely changed my perspective
on some people yes then we have and
we're going to start with this actually
because it's about to melt
but yesterday we talked about um the
questionable collaboration between van
luin and kraft mac and cheese ice cream
and the what did you know people at
crafta and lewin
sent us some ice cream to try now let's
do a little um
pre what's like when you give someone
like some notes before like a precursor
like a
what's it called preamble sure okay
here's the preamble
we don't have a freezer so it did arrive
this morning and we're doing our best to
keep it cold i'm sure it's quite soupy
in its texture but i guess that affects
us more than it affects you but
i think we could still give like a
pretty fair well-rounded are you gonna
eat it i feel like i'm gonna try but
like the
thought of it plus the soupiness and
it's morning and like my stomach already
feels like kind of iffy
no it's really scary so we'll look at it
we'll decide if we're going to try it
but i mean it really should have come
with some dry ice like no offense yeah
no but by the way i am trying it like
i'm just saying
okay okay yeah let's let's bring it out
bring them out
bring them out what's the consistency
like
there's a thing on top okay no the way
that it's that the way that it's
packaged
all right it does look okay allow me to
give you guys the full experience this
is the um pint ingredients are cream
milk cheese cream milk cheese
no it's cream milk cane sugar egg yolks
craft cheese sauce mix
okay so something don't give us the
ingredients okay
let's feel okay it's not soup but it's
not hard
okay that's good oh it looks like a
sorbet it's like a little melted it's
totally fine i mean it looks
it's literally the color of cheese put
it forward a little bit
i don't want to spill it okay fine okay
so we're gonna put it out here grab your
spoon
you take yours first and then pass it to
me okay it's actually
a delightful once you said sorbet now i
can look at it differently
i just want you guys to know that think
of it as a sorbet oh my god it
it really like if you look at it when
it's melted it looks like cheese it's
actually disgusting
um it doesn't smell like anything it
does smell like kraft mac and cheese a
little bit
wow no do i have covered against no it's
very faint
oh i'm getting nodes of cheese i'm
actually you have to go first i'm doing
something everything in my power
not to oh wait i'm i'm dripping you have
to go first
why i'm just saying i'm procrastinating
like so hard
what'd you do yesterday honestly a
horrible day can't wait about it
oh oh my god i literally took the small
side take a bite
but you didn't say how it was
it's disgusting that's the [ __ ]
craziest thing it tastes like
oh my god i'm spilling oh god wait we've
got cheese can i get a napkin
oh god you guys approach this that's
just saying that's the craziest thing
i've ever tasted
it's literal thank you so much oh my god
it's craft mac and cheese okay it's
craft mac and cheese
i stay in the couch [ __ ] it'll smell
like that forever
wait it says i'm here why craft mac and
cheese ice cream can you read that for
us
yeah that's a great question
have you ever met someone who didn't
smile while eating ice cream or smile
while eating a comforting bowl of mac
and cheese
yeah we didn't think i think we read
this propaganda
why not enjoy both at the same time in
the same bowl in the same mouth
you know you've always wondered what
this match up would taste like or at
least you do now
this is twisted absolutely vile shame on
everyone involved in this collaboration
for
i literally took the smallest bite i'm
right it's all over me
thank you all like the smallest bite
told us everything we needed to know
basically if you were to make craft mac
and cheese
drain the liquid and then put that in
the freezer
yeah that's what it tastes like it's
really nutritious what do you think
julian tried it so bad really bad and it
really tastes like mac and cheese
it tastes like the powder it really does
you know when you open the powder and
then it smells
and you get that fragrance that's
basically what the ice cream tastes like
chris
that is really crazy thoughts no it's
not for us
it's a no from all four of us okay it's
atrocious you guys like beware
honestly i feel bad because they sent it
to us but like but they send it to us
like with our horrible take on it yes
yes so honestly don't waste your money
twelve dollars a pint
one nerve that is just so crazy well i'm
glad we have that experience it's been a
while not since kevin o'leary have we
had a live taste test i know but i do
love eating on the show it's one of my
favorite pastimes
yeah so you know i'll continue to
deliver food news and we'll continue to
hope that someone hears it and sends us
we'll continue to use our platform to
get free food
essentially yes yes we will um how was
your day yesterday mine was like
booked busy packed caught up on so much
tv that i cannot wait to recap
for the purpose of this show made some
tick tocks none of them went viral and
it was pretty much a sad day for me
my day yesterday was so awful because
i woke up with a migraine i had a
migraine on the show yesterday i didn't
want to complain about it because i know
you guys are like tired
of me having migraines i went home and
suffered from my migraine
all day i had to sleep all day because i
couldn't watch tv i couldn't
read i had to cancel everything i had
planned like i could not get out of bed
so i literally slept into like on and
off until like eight o'clock when i woke
up
finally feeling better oh thank god oh
my god it was like my fever broke like
heaven
oh my heaven and then i caught up on all
the tv love island love island
roni and then i started a new book last
night so that i could fall asleep
having red and i was so worried i wasn't
gonna be able to fall asleep because of
yourself
but no yeah i fell asleep by like one
o'clock what is worse than having a
migraine and falling asleep and then
waking up and
still having the migraine no sleep is
supposed to be the cure like no
it was so crazy it was such a tough day
but i'm so
grateful for today you know like until
you if you're like a migraine girly like
me like you appreciate
the days of just feeling fine yeah so
much
well and if you're a migraine girl like
me who's triggered by the weather and
we're like currently living through like
this tropical storm
it's not good cloudy days rainy days
always give me migraines so i just know
one is coming my way
yeah so this week has tried me which
explains the juicy track suit
um you don't need to explain you look
great okay thank you i just like have
really been in a sweat state of mind
yeah and it's been like it's also for me
like a merch state of mind but i wanted
to wear like pants whatever you look
great
thanks so much so yeah i'm feeling just
grateful for today
for a new day for everything that this
day has in store for me for how much
i don't want to change my day because
watch migraine comes right back we were
just sleeping [ __ ] we're
literally still here um no but
now i can like you know do the things i
need to do there's nothing worse than
like having a day of literal
crossed off the calendar no productivity
can't even watch tv so it's not even
like fun yeah you know it's not like
sick you're staying home watching jeremy
yeah you know so were you a girl who
watched maury or jerry springer
when you were home from sick i was such
a mori girl
i don't know i really am not choosy hmm
not choosy at all
i used to like literally like fake six
so i could watch maury
yeah those were good times what it is
and was everything
good days so gotta get to a maury taping
didn't you already go i went to a jerry
springer table on the show
on the show i think that's better than
amore taping you know what i was
actually thinking we've had so many
guests on the show and i sometimes like
forget
and i was just recently thinking how
when we had chelsea handler on the show
that was probably like the most famous
person we've ever had
i think maury might be up there with
chelsea like
maybe even above her i think it just
depends
on who you're at you're asking you know
like
and what they value yeah because like
for some people it's derek kemsley
oh by some people do you mean you it's a
bigger guess than chelsea handler or
mari yeah no chelsea handler was like
such a big deal but then i'm like what
about maury
and why are you calling it mari because
we just have this like inside joke
between us oh you and mari do you mean
and you know what jackie you are not
the father um all right let's start then
because we've got a pretty long show for
you guys today um
there's a lot oh and we have dear
toasters there's right
to get through you know i was actually
thinking i wanted to bring this up to
you in private but i guess i'll just do
it in public and let everyone else weigh
in
i was thinking we might shift our deer
toasters
day a different day to tuesday because
the way our current tv is scheduled
we're not watching the bachelorette so
tuesday's shows are always a little
short
and then wednesdays have so much tv
recap and then dear toasters and i feel
like
wednesday's shows are like an hour and
15 minutes and tuesdays are like 40.
it's not balanced it's not balanced so
that's just an idea i'm throwing out i
my ruling we're moving deer toasters to
tuesday
yay oh my god i never come up with good
ideas
yeah no i think that's a really good
idea oh my god i meant to bring it up
yesterday but i obviously forgot
okay so next week you can expect your
toasters on tuesday wow this is a huge
shift
it is a cultural moment a reset in the
toast
yeah it's worth celebrating i say we go
to drinks tonight
yeah for sure can't wait can't wait all
right let's dive in because we actually
do have a lot to talk about
okay so without further ado do you want
to address that one
before we start where are you i don't
really feel like i need to explain
myself on
my parenting reasoning on hump day i
have a lunch
okay that's fine that's all you had to
say that's i just don't like being
questioned on like my decision making
when it comes to being a parent i don't
question you i don't feel like i was
doing any of those things
i was asking do where where do i just
like this pressure honestly like that
comes from you
consistently like i have a job to do i
can't constantly be bringing theo around
like i do it when i can
but you're always like pressuring me and
calling me out on the show and it's like
honestly i just can't i can't live up to
your expectations of me stop putting me
on a pedestal
yeah what goes through your mind
i'm 100 serious no i know okay um so due
has a lunch
and therefore without further ado it is
time for the fastback stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the one the only
the bruce the best electric toothbrush
on the market and the unofficial
official toothbrush of the morning toast
and the entire toast community
because everyone has gotten their bruce
over the last year and they're loving it
they got one for their husbands their
girlfriends their partners
spouses everything and you might be the
last person without a bruce
and who's not getting a premium dental
experience because the brush is the best
electric toothbrush on the market
really gets in there and it's very very
affordable because a lot of electric
toothbrushes can cost over two hundred
dollars which is insane
but the brush is fancy as hell and it
doesn't burn a hole in your pocket
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact travel case
so it's super easy to travel with they
also offer subscription programs so
uh they'll ship you new replacement
heads for your brush every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
like
frizzy ass miss frizzle brushes
you all know what she's talking about
yeah like you have been there when
you're using a toothbrush that looks
like
it drives the magic school bus you know
yeah the brush's sleek design
has a modern aesthetically pleasing
design that comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter they just came out
with new colors and we got them they're
kind of sickening like chanel
who get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit
and the refill plan when you use promo
code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using promo code toast at
bruush.com
sign on get your teeth right okay first
story emmy nominations 2021 claudia and
i don't really care about the awards but
i do like to know who's and what is
nominated to see if there's anything we
should be watching
emmy nominations 2021 are in and we were
snubbed
always we are always snubbed it's just
the name of the game it's the name of
the game
um the two biggest like nominees are the
mandalorian and the crown
oh the crown yeah so deserving so now
i'm going to take you through each
category and if you have a a favorite
just you know holler
yeah i realized like one or two years
ago i only watch bad television that
doesn't get nominated yeah
and honestly like if emmys were up to me
like monique samuels would be getting an
oscar i mean an emmy you know what i
mean but they're not so i
don't watch serious tv but i've seen
some shows so hit me with it okay
best actress in a comedy edie bryant
shrill kaylee cuoco the flight attendant
gene smart hacks alice and johnny mom
it's over
it's over jean smart hacks i've actually
seen every show in this category yeah
and i and i wanted also one more tracey
ellis ross blackish
i've seen it too she's excellent as well
i have something to say say it and it
pains me because i
i i so desperately wanted to like it and
relate to it the fact that
shrill is an atrocity it's
atrocious i agree the flight attendant
was good for cobin you know like
kayleigh was actually very good in it
and it was nice to see her in something
like
not dumb like the big bang theory she
was actually great the show was fine
she deserves it okay jean smart in hacks
have you seen that
not yet your husband watch it he watched
it it's on my plate like there are a lot
of shows here that i'm genuinely
going to watch this is at the top okay
no doubt it was the best show i've seen
in years i did a whole recap on it i
think when i after i watched it but
she deserves the win like give it to
like it's over like it was
so she was incredible like incredible
okay so that's your choice i didn't
think i would come into this emmy
nomination feeling so strongly no
there's a lot of shows in here that we
have seen i guess okay
wow okay i'm invested gene smart but not
but not in the next
category best actor in the comedy
anthony anderson blackish michael
douglas the kaminsky method
william h macy shameless jason sedakis
ted lasso keenan thompson keenan
everybody's always talking about ted
lasso and it is a part of my plate but
everyone likes yeah i think we need to
watch it
it's nominated so many times so many
people in it
you know i really feel like jason
sedagas needs a win after all he's been
through with harry styles so
and i think this is that win okay i
don't feel strongly about any
men in this particular category i do
watch shameless i haven't seen the most
recent season
um i just feel like i'm i'm a little mad
at william h macy do you know why
of course why because he just like let
his wife go through it
on her own he let his wife like take the
whole blame for the college admission
scandal and his life is so ineffective
like
laurie lachlan like try getting a job
will it major basically getting
nominated for emmys and it's like
technically they did the same thing
yeah well not technically because there
was like no paper
trail of him really participating in the
way that but his family did
no yeah but it's all about like who sent
right into evidence i understand it just
seems weird to me like
he just left his wife out to dry and
like let her go to jail it is a little
weird for sure okay
but maybe there was really nothing he
could do so why should the two of them
be suffered yeah and i mean they're
still married so like i think they've
worked through it
yeah and shameless is good so but yeah
no definitely that's the first thing i
think of
okay good because i feel like it's
literally the last thing people think of
because he was so not implicated at all
like
in the media in anything yeah best
supporting actress in a comedy
hannah ein binder hacks cecily strong
snl
edie bryant snl kate mckinnon snl juno
temple ted lasso hannah waddingham
ted lasso rosie perez the flight
attendant um
okay do you feel strongly about anything
in 100
like she's a runner she's a track star
she's yeah i think the girl hannah
einbender is that her name
i didn't think she was so great in hacks
like she was actually the one thing that
made me like
like be annoyed at the show okay good to
know yeah best supporting actor in the
comedy
carl clemens hopkins hacks bowen yang
snl keenan thompson snl brett goldstein
ted lasso brendan hunt ted lasso
nick mohammed ted lasso jeremy swift ted
lasso paul ricer the kaminsky method
okay so it's like the four shows that
are being nominated like ted lasso in
comedy so far this is oh right
and then these are the shows for best
comments from hacks
what's his name carl clements hopkins i
wonder who he played
he was a supporting actor yeah i'm
assuming maybe that's like her agent i
can't think of
any other
the assistant oh okay
show's best comedy okay blackish cobra
kai
emily in paris that is a joke that's a
really funny joke oh
oh that's a shitty hysterical that's
comedy this this is like these award
shows
want to be taken legitimate taken
seriously they want
and then they do this okay you're
kidding me there's more hacks the flight
attendant the kaminsky method pen 15
ted lasso hacks give it to hacks okay
moving on wait
i can't get over emily i know but like
what are we gonna do about it
talk about it it's crazy first of all
it's not a comedy
no at all second of all it's trash so if
this is the bar
where are the real housewives like
seriously yeah i'm shocked
where's why women kill literally oh
that's so funny that you mentioned that
i caught up on
the most recent season yesterday is it
worth for me to keep pushing through
yeah it's like frustrating almost being
a dumbbell
once alma okay just gonna spoil it
really quickly
once the neighbor did i talk about this
yeah we talked about it when the
neighbor fell
and she decided to call the police she's
gonna like team up with her murderous
husband and just hide the neighborhood
and it gets worse because they're so
dumb together i actually
can't watch i can't watch okay best
actress in a drama
emma carrin the crown uzo aduba in
treatment olivia coleman the crown
elizabeth moss the handmaid's tale
mj rodriguez pose journey smilet
lovecraft
country any relationship juicy
yes i believe journey is um
juicy's sister of but i'm just gonna
i'm gonna confirm that but i'm pretty
pretty sure got it
oh yes jurdy was in friday right sister
oh sister of jussis moulier she must be
so proud
um i don't really feel strongly about
any of these categories but happy for
all the winners
yeah i always love the crown you know me
yeah olivia coleman i would give it to
just because she's
iconic yeah she hasn't already won yet
for the role yeah i believe she has
best actor in a drama drama oh god oh
it's so dramatic
josh o'connor the crown billy porter
pose sterling k brown this is us
sorry when they release these lists they
should really put in parentheses what
their character's names is
sometimes in the crown i don't know any
of those people's names in real life
charles oh he was so good he made me
look like he was so bad it was
so good he actually was excellent yeah
reggie jean paige bridgerton
jonathan majors love cat country matthew
reese perry mason
so was the duke of hastings the only one
nominated from bridgeton
so far looks like it best supporting
actress in the drama
actually you know what i'm just going to
move on to the best drama because we got
to move quickly
best drama overall shows the boys them
boys and boys what shows that never
heard about richard
that's we love to see that the crown the
handmaid's tale
lovecraft country the mandalorian pose
this is us
this is us please this is a lot of
nominees like eight
yeah it is a lot best actress in a
limited series or tv movie
michaela cole i may destroy you oh i do
feel some type of way towards michaela i
do
i have no idea what that is or who that
is i'm rooting for k
cole oh you're rooting for kayla okay
yeah me too elizabeth olsen won division
i've never seen it but everybody's
talking about it i'm gonna add it to the
plate doesn't know if it's gonna get
eaten but
add to the plate it's been on my plate
for a while and it's starting to get
moldy like
it ain't happening cynthia arrivo genius
aretha
anya taylor joy the queen's gambit has
my vote all the way
kate winslet mara beaston olivia keeps
telling me to watch mayor of easton
east that's how the kids it's mayor of
east town
they say easton the ones who speak just
colloquially about it
no it's mayor of east like east and east
oh yeah for sure for sure yeah um okay
best actor in a limited series or tv
movie the limited series
are always the best like it yeah the
undoing hugh grant is nominated
oh my god i forgot about that show
whether that's nicole women was not
nominated
i think that's fair because i mean i
think they i think they both were really
good but
hugh grant his acting like was
impeccable it was impeccable like
were you a sociopath or were you not
like that's
true in terms of like out of the two of
them if only one of them had to get
nominated it should have been him but
like now that we know that emily in
paris is eligible for
some sort of nomination uh they should
just give it to nicole hidman you know
what i mean
paul bettany one division ewan mcgregor
halston
lin-manuel miranda hamilton leslie odom
jr hamilton from the hamilton that was
filmed
right right and put online very
interesting you know i actually take
back what i said when i said
that i'm probably not gonna watch the
emmys because i've never seen any of the
shows i've actually seen a lot of them
it was a great year for tv
yeah it was outstanding limited series
overall the underground railroad the
queen's gambit
i may destroy you one division mayor of
easton so
east town mayor of east town
so the undoing wasn't even nominated for
a limited series that's crazy because it
was really like a
cultural shift you know like we were
maybe it was like
not that good we were just so bored we
yeah it was good
it was that it was good enough but we
were also so bored
yeah i really do love a limited series
me too actually now that i think so many
of my favorite
shows like queen's gambit i think is
like the gold standard
yeah for television and it was a one
season one one division is a one season
wonder yeah also chernobyl that one a
few years ago if you guys haven't seen
it you've gotta
i haven't seen it and i feel like people
are always talking about like what
happened in chernobyl and i feel really
stupid because i have actually no idea
what the hell people are talking about
so you should watch chernobyl it's a
really crazy story i know i'm just like
in the middle of rupaul's drag race all
stars and like
no honestly like that's where my
priorities are and it's so good
okay that's oh you know what rupaul's
drag race is nominated
as it should be outstanding competition
program along with the amazing race
nailed it top chef and
this is the voice okay i feel like
rupaul's drag race wins every year and
they deserve to because they've really
put on
quite a show this past year we're so
grateful all stars
i have to say when i first started
watching i was like this is not it just
because like i didn't know any of the
queens and they're like kind of from old
older seasons
but i'm on episode three now
so good i mean obviously eureka wins
because she's
so it's actually crazy how famous she is
outside of the show like she had her own
show on hbo she's just like such a such
a star
also uh ginger minge is an icon and a
legend
and asia o'hara too nice okay there's
tons of other nominees but the show must
go on so check it out
um those are the big categories and you
know may the best show win even though
it probably won't because it's all based
on like
maybe whatever show tipped like bribed
the the
best get the most bang for their buck
and i guess that's going to be emily
paris
a hundred percent are you ready for our
next story
yeah kate moss is the new face of skims
i
saw wow inclined to skims on tuesday kim
announced kate moss as the new face
of her billion dollar shapewear and
loungewear line in skim's summer
campaign the 47 year old fashion legend
poses topless in boxer briefs from the
brand and other shots she models bras in
undies and shades of black white and
nude
kim said i first met kate in 2014
through ricardo tishi
and was instantly struck by her cheeky
humor authentic and classic beauty we've
been friends ever since
she is the fashion icon defining a whole
generation of style and i am honored to
feature her as the new face of skims
this summer
it's so true i mean first of all this
like is kind of like a really big deal
like
this makes skims like if if it weren't
already like the olympics making kim
skims so legitimate this just kind of is
like the
the nail in the coffin but like not in a
bad way like in a good way yeah the nail
in the
flower box or something um so
thrilling i was shocked when i saw it
and i just have to say literally
yesterday i ordered the olympics
collection
and i got an email the same day that it
chipped out so that's just customer
service for you
when i literally ordered that 818 vest
months ago and i got an email
this morning that it shipped oh well
that's exciting that shipped i'm
actually wearing skims today i'm wearing
a leotard underneath
my juicy tracksuit um what'd you get
from the olympics collection i
i was like so excited to buy stuff but
then when it was all broken out
singularly i was like oh there's not
actually anything that i need let me
tell you i got that like that i don't
know what other people call it i call it
the relaxation bra but
it's like a soft sleep bra that's what
she calls it um i got the white biker
shorts
like boxers bike biker shorts and um
pajamas like gray pants and long sleeves
pajamas are really comfortable yeah the
waistband is like a little tight
that's okay um i'm just so thin like it
doesn't
really affect me no that's just my take
um this is really exciting no i mean
page six styles has the best like she
was the face of calvin klein and now
it's the next
underline she's gonna do with skins like
that's actually so true
that's just an interesting factoid oh i
didn't even think of it like that and as
in like the underwear space
but that's a really good point it's just
it's a really big deal
very happy for her we saw them
gallivanting around rome together like
going to the vatican together
and i was like oh this is a cute
friendship didn't know it was layered
and i absolutely loved it i didn't know
it was also a business partnership
collaboration
yeah like kim probably expense to their
trip to the vatican because it's a
business thing maybe they shot schemes
in the vatican
that'd be sick that would be actually
like sick and twisted and
like really yeah yeah totally totally
totally
yeah so congrats to skim spam um
i feel like kim is just killing it like
she's coming out of this divorce like
really just an empowered woman
yeah making moves left and right can't
wait to see
where she what she does next who she
does next i know we're all waiting with
baited breath truly
are you ready for a little i guess
programming news
that i found interesting and i'm
personally happy about nicholas cage
won't portray
tiger king's joe exotic as amazon has
shelved the project
oh i think that's for the best no no
longer
relevant yeah after a highly anticipated
tiger
scripted series was announced last year
amazon and star nicholas cage have
chosen not to move forward with the
project
we should clear the record he said i
read two excellent scripts which i did
think were excellent
but i think amazon ultimately felt that
it was material that had become
past tense because it took so long for
it to come together yeah they felt at
one point that it was lightning in a
bottle but that point has since faded
into the distance and it's no longer
relevant
agreed thank you because if it would
have come out it would have like
continued this torturous like tiger king
that that torturous
tiger king is like honestly it's i don't
know if other people feel this way it is
symbolic it's
ptsd for me like it's symbolic of the
worst time ever
and honestly nicolas cage said it
perfectly like
if they had wanted to really capture the
momentum and and strike while the iron
is hot
it needed to have come out over a year
ago so the fact that it didn't and it
would have come out
maybe at the end of this year or next
year i'm so grateful to amazon nicholas
cage and everyone involved in that
decision
for not subjecting us to joe exotic like
now when i see things on joe exotic i
just like roll my eyes so hard like it's
not funny
agreed the only thing i just want to say
is like there were two projects
happening at the same time and the other
one
is still happening it's in the works at
peacock and that one is starring john
cameron mitchell and kate mckinnon
kate mckinnon would be a great carol
baskin um i do think that the amazon one
when there were gonna be two would have
been much bigger and much more
successful than the peacock one so i'm
less threatened by the peacock one
and hopefully this decision from amazon
will inspire those at peacock
to follow their lead yeah yeah i agree
and also just
even if there's one you know it's it's
less less than two it's less
it's less than two one is less than two
yeah one plus one equals sock don't
forget it
don't forget it and please forget joe
exotic like i'm so
out of that head space like even when
kim dressed up as him for halloween with
jonathan as
drugs out like i was so disappointed in
her lack of creativity like it's so
honestly chewy it's chugi
okay joe exotic is chugi yeah i just
still want to say i had never watched
tiger king
but i think you guys knew that oh my god
so you're talking all this no but like
that's how much like just the fanfare in
hawaii yeah you know
it was annoying and especially like
knowing i just know when my soul it
wasn't that good
no you don't need to know it in your
soul i could tell you it was not that
good
right ben was like obsessed with it
no i i seriously can't like it does
definitely
hark back to a very dark time yeah
there's like a couple tv shows or
activities like i honestly can't knit
anymore like i'm just brought back to
such a dark place in my life
yeah things that i really love to do at
the height of quarantine
that now if i pick it up i just like
shudder at the thought any other shows
there well i told you i watched rupaul's
drag race at like the worst time in
quarantine but the show is so good like
even the ptsd can't the other show that
i really think of in that like pocket of
quarantine that was like so isolating
is outer banks yeah and i actually just
saw
a headline that this season for the
trailer for season two just dropped and
i'm definitely gonna watch because i
liked it so much but like
i remember watching that after being
hung over after a zoom
um a zoom night out
twisted and like it just has that
association for me i
had a person so hung over from our zoom
yeah like
we used to get crazy on the zoom we used
to get crazy on the zoom
we drank so much no dead ass i actually
threw up one night
from the zoo one night i had five
of the double the big white cloth so i
had ten white claws
that's insane and i remember closing my
computer and we were done i'm like
walking down the hall and it's like
really like dizzying and i'm like i get
into bed i'm like man i think i'm gonna
throw up
and he's like go for it honestly white
cloth gives me that ptsd
because i really went hard on white club
like for the first time in my life
during coven
interesting that is so funny it's
embarrassing like what'd you do during
combat and i just
threw up like you just like had a bottle
of wine on soon literally it was so
pathetic
we did the most like i had bottles of
wine on zoom
yeah bottles no i remember um you and
margo were living like two blocks from
each other and someone
i finished my whole bottle of wine that
i got for the zoom for the big night out
and i actually met margo in the street
and she brought me another bottle of
wine
yeah like it was so desperate
[Laughter]
so desperate crazy times crazy times
so anyways nobody wants tiger king
anymore yeah that's the moral of the
story
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah it's a little history news i'm
sorry you guys but it's just so
interesting
the titanic news ocean gate submarine
makes a first dive to the titanic wreck
site and captures photos of debris
oh that's pretty sick um so you know the
titanic is still like
in the oceans no i did not know that
they did not excavate it because
doing so would kind of it's it's pretty
much like intact
underwater wow that's crazy um and so
some fish is like
living the life of luxury oh 100 first
class yeah literally like his palace
like
a yeah 100 um but the titanic is slowly
vanishing from the bottom of the
atlantic ocean
the victim of bacteria that's been
eating away at the ship's hull for
almost 110 years
this week the undersea exploration
company oceangate sent a team of
scientists 12
500 feet below to digitally map what's
left of the world's most famous
shipwreck the crew took photos of never
before seen artifacts including the
stained glass window and a piece of
floor tile
um isn't that littering
like dropping your boat in the ocean and
like not picking it up and the oceans
are already polluted
it's littering it's murder it's a lot of
things no i just like it's kind of weird
to me the concept like that they didn't
just
clean it up like well it took them a
while to find it it wasn't until 1985
that it was discovered
oh right i guess like no police came
like it was in the middle of the ocean
but they were saving like lives they
weren't going to like collect debris
got it and then it sunk yeah yeah and
then not until 1985 did they
did they find it at the bottom of the
ocean i just feel like in some ways i've
let my generation down because like
you and like so many everyone's like
obsessed with the titanic
and i didn't really even like the movie
and when's the last time you saw the
movie like i was like five
okay i saw the movie this is just like
this episode is always it's so much
about my drinking and my hangovers
we went to the bahamas a few years ago
and i got so
drunk one night i also think i was
poisoned because like i was
so sick i was so i
i could not leave the hotel room and
titanic was on
vh1 or whatever mtv and i watched the
whole movie with commercials and i was
so fascinated riveted that i had to like
go and learn so much
more stuff about it and you need like
you need to watch it
as an adult but i just like hate
watching movies
where like something sad happened so
like the whole time it's like rose i'm
the king of the world
and then it's like we just know all
these people spoiler alert like are
gonna die and it's sad like i don't like
that it gives me pith
yeah i know but while you're watching it
you're like maybe they could maybe
victor garber could swerve on this
iceberg
can we also talk about how watching a
movie on cable is literally the most
torturous thing ever yesterday i watched
bohemian rhapsody while i was eating
dinner the commercials
were killing me like every five minutes
it's such an unenjoyable experience
i kept thinking to myself i understand
people who cut chords like
this is torture yeah no it was it was
rough but that's how that's how
engrossed i was in the film
that i sat through every single
commercial and you know it's like a four
hour movie
right six hours with commercials you
should really it was my whole
hangover yeah you should really watch it
it's such a fascinating crazy story
i'll think about it so many great celeb
cameos
yeah victor garber victor garber is the
ship's captain and he tried but
other forces were trying to get there
they were trying to break the record of
not only does have to be the biggest
nicest ship to cross the sea but get
there the fastest time
they were moving they were doing too
much they were doing the most yeah i did
see a conspiracy theory actually
on tick-tock um completely unverified
that like the titanic was done on
purpose
because like one of these really rich
guys
was on it and he was like blocking some
decision at the federal reserve i don't
know
so they had to kill 1500 people right
yeah it was a it was a major stretch
but like because that guy did die today
we have the federal reserve or some some
[ __ ] like that
interesting sent it to me yeah no it
actually like kind of tracked
that's really crazy yeah and they just
haven't like had one agent just throw
them overboard
no right like why kill all those
innocent lovely families
yeah i don't know anyways that's your
titanic news of the day and i feel so
you need to know it and if you haven't
watched titanic as an adult
treat yourself and if you're an adult
who only recently found out that it's
based on a true story and all those
people did in fact die
don't fret because i was there like a
year ago but other people survived too
they didn't yeah there were life boats
they were not yes there were not enough
that's not the truth the love story is
not true no but rose technically
survived on the door
there were life boats on the boat and
once again there were not enough
lifeboats for how many passengers were
on the boat there was never going to be
but you know they had women and children
get on some of the lifeboats and um
some people survived interesting yeah
you should watch it
no because that scene you know the scene
all the water starts like running down
the hallway yeah
and then all the gates come down yeah
honestly like i can't watch it
it's so it's so upsetting you're right
and actually watched another tick tock
of how they filmed that scene with the
water
wow um very complex i can't really
explain it to you in layman's terms
you'll have to watch it anytime you see
a titanic ticket i will
i should read a book about the titanic
yeah you should are you ready for our
fifth and final story
wow so fast yeah it's a little poop news
i think i'm okay we already ate the
craft mac and cheese ice cream
tel aviv will test dog poop dna to find
owners who don't clean up
i actually meant to send this to you
because i wanted to talk about it on the
toes so i'm so glad you brought it
up tel aviv has found an innovative way
of dealing with dog owners who don't
clean up after their pets in the city
streets
texting testing the excrement's dna and
sending a fine to the owner by mail the
city council on monday approved a motion
setting up
a dna database and stating that dog
owners will be required to submit their
pets genetic details
to authorities upon receiving or
renewing a license this is so
funny this is so crazy let me tell you
why and i feel
a many a different way about it but i
just love that tel aviv's like
so focused on like cleaning up their
city you know and i wish we had that
sort of energy here because like
i don't i'm not even worried about dog
[ __ ] i'm worried about stepping on like
used needles
and chicken wings like it's just wild
out here so jealous of that
now as a writer it's like how much stuff
have they cleaned up to get to the point
of evaluating dog poop dna they must
have no other they might be
trash problems it must be the last
remaining you know
obstacle in the street in the littering
realm
yes so here are my thoughts as a dog
owner and as a pedestrian
i'm i'm thrilled about the decision and
also
slightly annoyed if it were me if i
lived in tel aviv or if we had that law
here because
it's so disgusting like i see it all the
time poop on the street it like
flies swarm it like it's vile especially
in the summer like it smells people
don't notice they step in it it's just
like
so torturous but
as dog owners sometimes
duty calls you're not prepared and what
are you supposed to do pick it up with
your hands
theo's leash doesn't have poop bags on
it okay so i don't know if other dog
owners have this problem
because i've never i had the uh bruno
poop and i didn't have what to pick it
up okay that happens to me all the time
i've bought
a thousand and one of those little leash
clip-ons
yeah you clip it on and then you refill
it somehow
one way or another a week later is gone
whether it's ben or the dog like it's
always gone so i don't always have no
i don't always have a bag okay well i
feel like if this were to come to your
city like you could be better prepared
like
bruno's leash has this whole contraption
on it that has treats
and bags with it and it doesn't just
disappear because it's like part of the
leash
yeah um so you have to just be better
prepared yeah
and you know what that's a small price
to pay to clean up these streets i know
it is like a little like no offense for
like it's a little invasive like for the
dogs
yeah like to be embarrassed like that
and what is the process of getting your
dog's
[ __ ] into the database your dog's dna i
think it's like when you register your
dog for like their license and their
chip and whatnot
you are also they take a big i feel like
that's hard to maintain like how are you
gonna
and who's testing it like is it is are
there police officers who come around
and test aaron poop or they don't get
paid enough
or is it civilians like oh there's a
poop i'm gonna it's a citizen's arrest
so i look forward to hearing more
details about this um it's really crazy
but you know what you gotta do what you
gotta do
you gotta do what you gotta do today
yeah so true i think it's an interesting
concept i'll
i'm curious to see how it works out
anything that will strike fear
into the people who don't pick up their
dog's poop and maybe they'll pick it up
more it reminds me of like those
swimming pools where if you pee
yeah the water and it's like i've
actually never been in a pool where that
happened
but once i heard that they might exist i
i mean i'm not someone
maybe as a kid i peed in the pool more
you know if we're having a good time and
i just didn't want to get out
but um i definitely was always in the
front of my mind like oh
i should go use the restroom yeah no
it's a scare it's a fear tactic i
too don't know if those pools actually
exist but the thought that you might be
in one
is enough to make you just get up and go
pee and not pee in the pool a hundred
percent and starts getting like purple
all around
yeah again have never actually seen it
in practice but it's like i don't know
if it's like an
urban legend or something but it might
it's a [ __ ] genius
genius it's like i think that's actually
something like boomers did
to scare our generation and i think it
works i know we need to instill it in
our children as well
100 um let's dive into the tv recap
segment which is brought to you by
halo collar you guys know our dogs bruno
and theo
are a huge part of our families and
that's why when it comes to keeping
theo and bruno safe happy and secure we
knew that the halo collar was the only
color we could use
halo is the only smart system with a
collar that trains tracks and protects
your dog
so they can safely run free they set up
halo fences by walking with the
perimeter around your with your collar
or at the touch of your finger in the
halo app you can train with natural
simple profound communication via the
custom feedback you set for your dog
it can even include in your voice you
can stay connected to your dog and see
how they're doing from activity to
safety status anytime you want
it has gps without cell or wi-fi and you
can create up to 20 fences instantly
the included 21-day training program
sets you up for success
so if you want to learn more about halo
they have a 90 second video
on shop halocolor.com toast to set it up
we have both used it now for a few
months it's so premium
love the gps feature so easy to set up
love having it all on your phone in the
app it's just like really
even if you're not technologically savvy
i feel like you can set it up really
really fast
i mean there's so many advantages like
if you have a yard and you want to set
up fences
it's really smart take advantage of the
special limited time introductory offer
today
save 20 on your halo collar by going to
shop halo collar dot com slash toast
that's shop halo collar dot com slash
toast
to save the 20 and you must use that
link to get the 20 off
it can only be gotten at shop
halocolor.com
toast sign on protect your pups it's the
only thing that matters in the slides
it's so true all right let's take a trip
to salem pa
no massachusetts m.a and
talk about the real housewives of new
york last night because i actually
have something to say i have something
to say i don't know where everyone else
stands i just need to plant my
flag in the ground and let you know that
i'm 100 team rashawn me too
100 let me tell you why please do one
because
she's interesting like there was
actually a fight thank god
two she's not wrong bless you
sneezed on it it's true she's completely
justified in saying
you guys are like grandmas you're kind
of boring she thinks she's going on a
real
housewives girls trip she shows up to
look at an
old 1600s cabin and eat at a library
like
she's a hundred percent she's 100 right
if you look at the group
two of the women are sober sonia can't
have more than one drink
ebony's dealing with grief and tragedy
and so it's just ramona who's there like
ready to dance on tables like
you women like no offense because
everyone has their own stuff going on
but you're boring your grandma's i'm
sorry by the way i don't even think you
need to drink to not be boring but my
god are ebony and leah boring another
ebony uh leah and luanne boring
a hundred percent i am someone who like
we could go on a girl's trip and maybe i
won't drink and you would say you're
boring your grandma and it's like i know
and this is my choice like
for them to get so defensive over her
calling them grandma's like when there
was no lie involved
it was really so crazy when like and
they came for her
so so hard so leah and ebony like
getting up and leaving like
the fact that they sat in the restaurant
in the hamptons while sonia morgan had a
complete [ __ ] breakdown saying such
mean things to ramona about how mario
left her doesn't love her saying like
such mean things
nobody said anything nobody got up from
the table but when bershon called sonia
a clown sorry which was funny
uh everyone suddenly has this moral
compass that's leading them out of the
restaurant like it's so dramatic and
like
they're making her feel so much worse
she didn't do anything
that crazy like no and she was just
stirring [ __ ] up and like it was time
something needed to be stirred
yeah 100 also her calling sonia clown
like
twerking like that's exactly what sony
does that's what i was trying to say
yesterday when we're talking about like
the women
who behave badly and it's like it's
sonia she is a clown like she's her
elevator she can even stand up right
like and she says it herself she can't
have like more than one drink which she
often does and like
clown comes out where was the lie
no she's speaking facts 100
and also leah and ebony are just like
kind of hypocritical because the
whole time they've been like everyone's
swimming to sonja like making fun of you
know her talking about her past life
and then literally at that 1600s cabin
wherever the hell they were
they're talking so much [ __ ] about sonia
they're doing the exact thing that
they've accused everyone of doing all
seasons right and you know what it's
taken luanne and
ramona about 10 seasons to really like
you know hit sonia with tough love and
not be able to put up with it anymore
it took leah and ebony three episodes
yeah before they're like we can't hear
this anymore yeah so i just thought the
whole episode was so
hypocritical and so boring like she's
right like you girls are boring
and i feel like it was really symbolic
of like what housewives should be and
what housewives
is currently like bershon probably knows
what the show is about
thinks she's gonna come and have a great
time and literally they're sitting in a
library
yeah and i get like covet of course but
you gotta make something happen like
come on no and it's also because a lot
of them
don't drink and unfortunately that is
where
like a big source of drama i think
sometimes and especially with these
women in the past like
it goes to a place where it's not
entertaining at all
but you know with all the other shows
it's like you know liquid a little bit
of like
courage and they definitely get into
worse fights than they would if they
weren't drinking
right so but sometimes the show drinks
so much that they all go crazy and in
the morning they don't remember and they
don't like care to
and then it's just stupid because we're
going in circles like with no point that
was like when dorinda was on the show
yeah vershawn was 100 right they're
having like this dinner with like red
wine
and they're just like sitting there and
it's boring and it's been a boring trip
so far
so boring and just think about the day
that they've had like just think about
the day
they literally went to that like
colonial i don't know what it was like
pilgrim house yeah pilgrim looking at
like the outhouse
and then they go to a quiet dinner drink
red wine and are supposed to she's like
where are we going the library which is
so appropriately named
it's just so she's right like it's so
boring yeah and this is not what she
signed up for
no and so i think everyone was like so
defensive and heated i think
i really i mean all season they clearly
seem to think that like people are going
to agree with them
yeah and i don't i don't know i read
some tweets and it seemed like people
were like thank god for barshawn like
yeah things up
um i don't know where everyone else
stands but like
i thought the reaction was so
unwarranted and
then when they got back to the library
ebony and leah telling bershon that
ramona set her up
i didn't really follow that logic
because basically rashawn was just doing
like housewife things she's like
oh lee i don't know why everyone hates
you you're great like that's what
housewives do
and then they somehow are saying like
ramona set her up when i don't think
ramona is like that
calculated and manipulated no and also
when they flash back to ramona
talking to bershon about leah like i
thought everything ramona said was
actually really respectful and
truthful but also like not rude at all
and it's crazy because like leah expects
ramona to speak
so glowingly about her in front of her
behind her back
when leah says the absolute worst things
to ramona
about sonia she called sonia was like i
just spoke to ramona she gave me a
splitting headache like
she leah cannot is leah comes so hard
for ramona but also like ex
like thinks that they're friends and
expects ramona to say nothing but nice
things about her when like
leah is so disrespectful towards ramona
so i actually think what
ramona said about leah was really nice i
think leah might be having one of the
worst
sophomore seasons of any housewife in
history how she went from being so
beloved
to so hated like by everyone unanimously
is shocking
yeah i did like the moment where um
ebony revealed that her grandmother had
passed away that morning and like ramona
and all the women like stood up and were
like hugging her um
i thought it was sweet and like it had
been such a weird night before that
and i think it was like kind of the
unifying moment that they all needed
even though i didn't understand lee
like breaking down and crying like
making it about herself right
i imagine she was crying because of
herself
like just grandmother's passing yes is a
hard topic for her right yes
yeah it was just like a kind of twisted
episode sonia morgan figuring out how to
drink red wine through her face mask was
i was shocked yeah like in tears yeah
it looks like next week they're going to
talk to her like about her drinking yeah
they used they did that a couple seasons
ago
and i actually really thought that she
didn't have a drinking problem because
she didn't go a few seasons as dead
sober and she's
she wanted to prove everyone like i'm
not a drunk like i
drank a lot but i can also not drink i
don't think that she's like a drunk i
just think alcohol really hits her in a
wrong way
you know like almost like she's allergic
yeah like the slurring and
because it her tolerance is so low yeah
yeah but the and maybe it wouldn't have
seemed like such a big deal if this no
one in this group was drinking and this
group was actually phillips full of
sober women like yeah
maybe it just stands out more because i
feel like she's actually had it really
under control for
a while but this is just like not a turn
up group anymore like at all
not at all and i also think it's
retirement central after last night's
episode
um this rumor that ramona is the one
who's gonna be fired like
that's again like not the the remedy for
the season yeah no i agree like ramona
not being there last night would have
done nothing i really do like rashawn
though i think she has major potential
me too i hope they don't like shut her
out after this
yeah um and then love island was on yes
and i just want to just say my thoughts
on the episode that came before last
night
that you had shared because it was
interesting to see things shaken up
i take back what i said about shannon
because i thought i thought in the first
episode like she i didn't like her
attitude but then
i really liked how she came for josh
laid it all out there like didn't mince
words like
let him know how she felt and also was
like vulnerable enough to
you know would rather be interested in
him and see where it goes than like
just boot him from the show and you know
prematurely so
um yeah it was it was definitely
things are picking up i thought last
night's episode was so good
first of all the cinco cache trina love
triangle has left me feeling shook and
let me tell you why
because when when cinco and cashie kind
of ended up as a couple not by choice
just kind of by default
i was like all right they'll they'll
find other people for each other and i
didn't really ship them but i feel like
they really built like something nice
like they have a nice friendship and
even when they show like the
whatever how long conversations that
they have on like the bench or whatever
like they're always laughing
they're laughing and their conversations
are substantial as opposed to other
people it's like
how are you feeling i feel like it's a
good vibe between us like the way that
they talk like
the whole show is really i know people
talking about
things like their feelings and things
but not really like acting on their
feelings yeah
and but i i don't feel that way with
cinco and cash like i feel like they're
having real conversations
a hundred percent and so when trina and
don't get me wrong i really do feel bad
for treating like jeremy
[ __ ] her like she has nothing going on
right now um so when she was like being
a jezebel like running around the house
like trying to kiss
cinco i was really upset with her for a
multitude of reasons one
cachet is her friend and they had like a
really nice conversation at the
beginning of the show being like
we are sisters like no one can
understand like what it's like to be
here as a black woman i felt like they
had a really strong bond
and for her to just like go behind her
back and try and kiss her man when
cashier is like so
into cinco i was really mad at her like
for real and i thought
cashy's response was completely
appropriate and their conversation like
cashier just [ __ ] let it out
i love when people are like let me
finish it's just the best like i love it
so i i'm okay whatever so they worked it
out but trina is still actively pursuing
cinco and i don't know how i feel about
that in the beginning i really shipped
it but now it's like girl
you waited too long sorry it's been a
day no it's been like five episodes okay
i swore i hear what you're saying but i
feel a little bit differently because i
i want trina to find the love that she
so
desires not with cingo but the name of
this game is like they are
still in their first week of being
coupled up cinco and cash really and
like
you gotta explore your connections and
trina and cinco will have a connection
i know it was really sad during the
kissing booth challenge which i want to
talk about in a minute when they were
kissing and cashier was like
she like admitted like that she could
have seen her and that like maybe
it should be trina and not her but that
just made me sad because like
cash deserves love she's such a good
friend to all the girls and like she's
really like probably out of all the
girls
one i feel like i know the best yeah she
actually opens up
yeah i i agree the kissing challenge was
like really crazy there's too much
kissing and challenges
and not enough kissing outside of
challenges that kind of bothers me about
the show because it's like
it's just too much kissing for when
they're not like romantic
romantic you know what i mean yeah
that's actually a really good point how
like they really never kiss except for
will
except when they're like dared to kiss
me and kiera like there's oh my god so
they're like kind of annoying me they're
annoying they are because they are like
so attached so hot and heavy and like
that fizzles out so fast i do feel like
it's a flame that's gonna fizzle quickly
when he raided her kiss at nine i was
like
he said it was a nine and then when he
was talking with the guys he said it was
like such a different kiss they've never
kissed like that before it was so
intense they were so connected so why'd
you give it a nine
i don't know he was just lying like
maybe he's just like a really harsh
critic like dana will read a book on
redheads and be like it was the best
book i ever read
so incredible 4.2 got it you know
honestly the best part of the episode
was when they both separated the girls
and the boys and they were talking about
who was the best and worst kissed her
because when they all agreed that jeremy
was the worst kisser i swear to god
i lost my mind jeremy has went from
being like my favorite person in the
house to me wanting to see him fail
so badly like i'm so mad at what he did
to trina and i was just kind of a loser
and honestly the stuff that trina was
saying to him
amy is now also saying to him like he
doesn't know how to be in a relationship
he doesn't know how to be like
affectionate or like show interest and
it's like
frustrating to be in a couple with him
yeah he needs to give more
i still really like him and i felt like
amy's speech about him was really nice
when she coupled up with him and she's
like you're like the angel of the house
which
makes me feel good about him but he
needs to give more in a relationship or
else amy is going to
walk out the door yeah and amy like is
actually really beautiful
like sickeningly stunning every time i
see her i see her like with a different
face yeah like sometimes she looks like
miley cyrus yes like she's so
complex looking she's gorgeous she is
gorgeous
i agree like she styles herself do you
think isaiah is going to choose her
or shannon oh i feel like shannon
you think yeah he spoke to her twice and
only amy once
do you think i don't know i don't know i
don't know him well enough yet
do you think cinco is going to choose
cash or trina
i feel like his head is telling him
cash but his heart is telling him trina
but maybe him and trina just have like
sexual tension and there's no
relationship there whereas like him and
cash actually
they're teetering on between having like
one of the most healthy relationships or
like a pure platonic friendship like
i can't tell i feel like they actually
might be really good friends yeah i feel
like if he
chooses trina like he might regret it
really quickly
but if he chooses cash even if it
doesn't turn into like this big romance
like
he would never regret it it's like the
solid thing to do i know and i just feel
like
i just feel like they really could be
like otp like i really
when he brings her tea like i swear to
god like i lose my mind he's so sweet
oh my god when he brings her to you
twice in the same saw that i was like i
want tea no trina saw that and wanted to
jump off the cliff like yeah
literally he's and she could have had it
like he was so
he just got paired up with cache because
there was no one else
and and he was interested in trying and
she went for jeremy yeah
but that's also on trena because jeremy
like he doesn't give much
no and she was just like chasing jeremy
for no reason
and also like what we did see of their
relationship like there wasn't
substantial conversations being had no
and that's jeremy that's on jeremy he's
like
kind of a loser like i really went from
like being obsessed with him and now i'm
like
i hope everyone breaks up with you like
i just hate him i'm not there yet with
him but i could i understand you're
feeling you'll get there don't worry i
understand how you're feeling i
shouldn't say i'm really loving the
journey
of like watching love island it's so fun
to have something like serious like not
serious but and good to watch every
night
something else to keep in mind is there
is a winning couple
at the end of the show that the fans
vote on everyone's favorite couple i
don't even know if that couple
is together yet because i don't think
there's anyone strong enough usually
it's the people who have been together
the longest but yeah sometimes they also
have to have like a really
they have to be two people that you like
so much what are these people just be
smart and like
stay with cash and say go and be so cute
the whole time like just so they could
win
do you win money yeah you win money and
at the end so it's a hundred thousand
dollars
and then the couple wins and they each
vote if they want to share the money
or keep the money if they both say share
they get to share it
if one of them says keep in the other
says share the keeper the keeper wins
so it's like dude were you in it for the
money or were you in it for the
relationship oh that sounds good
yeah um it's a final twist love to see
it
um so we'll keep we'll probably do one
more this week
yeah um it's just good like i'm enjoying
my life i'm so glad and ben is obsessed
he couldn't believe i watched it without
him last night because he was playing
monopoly
oh yeah and so i had to like in bed like
tell him all the cache cinco drama like
it was so dramatic who does he favor
um trina yeah i think he just like
thinks she's hot so
he doesn't like he's not as invested
emotionally yeah and like the layered
feeling yeah he's just like
and the friendship but she's cute yeah
yeah um all right dear toasters coming
up our advice segment is brought to you
by the pill club
life is stressful enough access to
health care shouldn't be luckily getting
birth control is one of
one less thing you have to worry about
because with pill club you'll never have
to make a trip to the doctor or wait in
line at the pharmacy again
they provide access to care from the
comfort of your home and delivery to
your door in very discreet packaging
so if you need to renew your birth
control you want to switch your birth
control maybe try it for the first time
whether you know the brand you want or
you want help finding the best option
the pill club
medical team has your back the pill club
is a birth control subscription
prescribed by a medical professional and
delivered straight to your door for free
they carry over 120 fda approved brands
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as nine
dollars per month without insurance
the pill club delivers birth control to
your door for free in discreet packaging
and right now when you go to
thepillclub.com toast
the pill club is offering a 10 donation
to bedsider.com
for every morning toast listener who
becomes a patient your donation will
help low income individuals get access
to birth control
through bedsider.org that's
thepillclub.comtoast to get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control
remember that's thepillclub.comtoast
make sure to use that link if you want
the donation thank you for that
okay ready hello my queens claudia and
jackie
again if you ever want to write in
deartoasters gmail.com i'm beyond
obsessed with the toes literally
listened to ten thousand minutes of the
podcast last year according to spotify
i've been hesitant to write in but i
desperately need your advice i'm a 26
year old virgin and trying to change
this
asap i've always dealt with self-esteem
issues because of this whenever anyone
would show interest in me way back in
high school i would avoid it
the one then once i got to college i was
beyond embarrassed that i had no sexual
experience with anyone so yet again i
would avoid any advances guys make it
made
i felt like everyone else knew exactly
what they were doing except for me
it got to the point when where people
assumed i had done it and truthfully i
wouldn't correct them so i was terrified
of being caught
by being obviously inexperienced in the
bedroom i did every other normal college
thing had
had ton of close guys and girlfriends
partied pretty hard overall super social
just couldn't get myself to do anything
with a guy
this has become a very vicious cycle
fast forward to now i'm still not
i'm still in the same boat i don't have
any friends because i moved to a new
city right before the pandemic
and i am in a leadership position at
work so i can't mingle with my staff
i'm so ready to get my lack of
experience over with so i can start
living my life i truly don't even know
where to start or what to do
do i find a random hookup and how go on
the apps and hope to open up to the
right guy who won't think i'm a freak
at what point do i bring up my
experience before we meet in person
how do i get this over with just for
some context i live in a big itch city
so lots of people and lots to do
i haven't tried dating apps in six years
no recent pictures and i'm working on
losing my quarantine weight same
so i'm not confident with my looks but
i'm so desperate i don't know if i even
care
signed an embarrassed toaster okay
i really want to change like the whole
way you're looking at this situation
because it sounds like you're just
wanting to give away your flower
you are in a place in your life where
you're like not respecting yourself and
that's just the worst you will feel so
bad afterwards trust me like
you will hate yourself for making a
decision in haste
decide in haste repentantly like
i think you need to have a complete 180
on your mindset like you are
a vision like your virginity and i don't
like
in our society not to get all preachy
but
we're like being a virgin is a negative
thing like it's your decision it's not a
big deal like it's really not and i just
think like
the way you're looking at this whole
situation you need to completely turn
around because
you need to put some value in yourself
look at yourself you are a prize
you are prize really
it's not it's not a bad thing at all and
it's not such a big deal
and you don't need to like go out and
meet someone just to lose your virginity
i'm pretty sure you will feel really
badly if you do that you'll feel badly
afterwards
i think the way that you should approach
it is just the way you should approach
looking for a relationship
first of all i totally understand
gaining quarantine weight like i feel
you to my core
um but the people that you're going to
meet now don't know what you used to
look like so true
you know like find like
you can still continue on your journey
but like try and find a way to be like
confident in who you are right now right
and so much of how other people perceive
you is how you perceive yourself
how you present yourself and if you're
just like doubting yourself feeling
down on yourself that other people can
read that and it's like if you're this
confident queen it doesn't even matter
like if you're wearing makeup like
people see the confidence shining
through it's so true like the
the way you look at yourself is really
how other people begin to look at you
it's the energy
you put out definitely so i would say
first we need
we need to do it inside out like
makeover almost
and i think for me like if you want to
start getting out there now like
go shopping get some stuff that you feel
good in right now you know the other
stuff will wait and we'll come in time
but like
get some clothes that you want to go on
a date on that you feel your best in
yeah go to a spa get a manicure
yeah like and then get out there and i
think you should be looking for
a relationship and i think once you find
a relationship with the right person
like the right person is actually going
to be like oh that's kind of
relieved right like the virginity thing
it's it's like
it's really not so it's not everyone's
getting over it i'm sure you'll
like i have only been with one person
and it's like such a relief like i don't
have to worry about where ben's dick has
been like
it's there are lots of cons i'm just
saying i mean no sorry
pros there are lots of pros and don't
just like do it to get rid of it
because you've waited this long it means
something to you as you know it means to
a lot of people
so just don't like take a step back be
easy on yourself
and in the words of rupaul if you can't
love yourself how in the hell you gonna
love somebody else
yeah um i agree i actually think that
was really good advice yeah definitely
go shopping make some investments okay
second-tier toasters jack and claudia
i'm an overly paranoid person so i'm not
sure if i should be putting my house on
the market
or not a little background a few years
ago i babysat for a neighbor
when the dad relieved me he talked my
ear off that evening i had a facebook
friend request from the dad and this
strange account that was linked to his
dad's business
i ignored both because i only used
facebook for the toast groups and i
thought it was weird
lol well last week i was at the pool and
the dad was there with one of the
children
we had a friendly exchange because i'm
polite but i was there hanging out with
my mom
oh and he's married with two kids well
later that night i had a friend request
from that same strange facebook at this
point it's clear it's his burner account
i ignored it
a day later i got a message that said
hey brit john here
not our real names oh no i think she's
telling me that they're not our real
names okay
i thought he messaged her yeah like with
fake names
okay so he messaged her hey brit john
here
so now i confirmed that it was him again
i ignored it well last night at 2am he
liked a facebook post of mine from 2010.
at this point i blocked because i'm
freaked out that's him using his burner
account three separate times to try to
get my attention since the pool
the friend request the message and the
like what the [ __ ] do i do
so far i drive by the pool before
heading down there to make sure he's not
there
his wife is a sweet woman but i don't
know either of them very well
my plan is to avoid but they live almost
directly across the street for me i'm so
freaked out
i'm a single 30 year old and he's a
married 50 year old what if he's a
psycho and doesn't take it well
that i'm ignoring him and decides to
stalk me in person instead of online
is it all innocent what do i do xoxo if
i die please turn this over to the
police
but really you know this is really tough
because there's so much weirdness here
but also there is like a level of
weirdness that comes with 50 year olds
being on facebook and like i act
i don't know the situation enough i
could see him being like a freak dad
who's like hey
brit it's me yeah but also to be
connected yeah right like people
adults on facebook are so weird but i
don't take [ __ ] like this lightly like
it is weird
i don't know if you should like i don't
know if we're overreacting or like under
reacting like should you move i don't
know
this sounds like a lifetime movie i
watched once with the babysitter and dad
and
and was it twisted in the end oh it was
twisted it always is i don't really
remember everything
but i just remember this premise um yeah
no it's definitely weird i would
continue
to ignore her as best that you can
obviously you can no longer
sit on those kids and you'll have to
find new campers to work with
um and just hope that he gets the
message and even if whether it's being
friendly or creepy
you have made it clear that you're not
interested in pursuing any sort of
uh relationship with him and then if if
it's still like if it gets weirder and
weirder
you can take other measures yeah i would
continue to monitor the situation don't
write it off as just like weird old
people things
just continue to monitor it and if it
does get weirder it takes it to another
level like
move immediately because those
situations like never end well
i know but that's like so drastic i know
if you like love yourself maybe there's
other things you could do first like
tell his wife
oh yeah but would you anger him then and
then it said you have to live across the
street from like this couple that you
like through right
and like maybe the wife becomes a [ __ ]
and thinks you're like some you know
babylon they start plotting yeah because
wives can be helpful
but they can also be destructive like if
you bring them in they get like weirdly
defensive and insecure
yeah because it's like why would i trust
this babysitter over my husband
20 years right right that's a tough
situation
i'm not gonna lie continue to monitor it
i don't think you're overreacting
i think it's something you should be
aware of because in this day and age
like people are freaked out do you like
your house do you like your neighborhood
is it right have you been working to
move how are home prices in your
neighborhood you know it is a really
good time to sell your home because
everyone's just clamoring
out of the cities so maybe it's a good
time for you to move yeah good financial
move
yeah our third and final deer toasters
is an update
dear claudia and jackie a few months ago
i wrote in on how my husband's family
was excluding us from family events
due to them thinking i was rude to his
grandmother i wanted to give you all an
update
things are a little bit better but they
have turned competitive maybe i'm being
dramatic you tell me
the cousin that excluded us has now
started inviting us to their barbecues
or parties
but we had a fourth of july barbecue in
the late afternoon at 5 p.m and i found
out that this particular cousin was
having a barbecue just after mine
she invited the same exact people to her
house that i invited to mine but
excluded to invite us
the cousin and her family showed up to
our house for maybe 45 minutes and then
left early to set up for their barbecue
so after everyone left our barbecue they
all proceeded to go to her house for her
barbecue
now i feel like i'm in this weird
competition with her like when i just
want to get my husband's family together
for a holiday
my husband says i'm making a big deal
over nothing but i feel like his cousin
is now doing this to out
doing this to me out of spite since
she's the one that said i was rude to
her grandmother i could really use your
advice a sincerely a toaster with
dramatic in-laws okay
you know sometimes i just feel like
relationships aren't worth keeping and
this is like one of them like
seriously you're you're not related to
this [ __ ] and she's making it so hard
for you to get her family together like
go [ __ ] yourself
okay sorry that's claudia's take my
advice was just going to be
it's only a competition if two people
are participating but if it's good
advice
if your outlook is like i don't care
what you're doing i love my party we're
doing my thing and
i have the party from five to seven
whatever you do afterwards is your thing
like
if you just couldn't look at it
differently and just disengage honestly
from this competition
then i think it's all about your mindset
you're letting her get to you
as opposed to just being like i doing
what i want to do and whatever you're
doing that's cool too but like
i like what i'm doing see that's like so
mature but it's just annoying that she
has to do this like
why doesn't this [ __ ] just stop you
know like we have to dance around this
crazy cousin like
do you know what i'm saying no i do but
you know what that's life dancing around
i know it's so true but honestly like i
would just cut this [ __ ] out of your
life she sounds so toxic no but she
had said in the other one that like her
husband's family is like so important to
him
like the grandma and like it's it's not
like you just cut out a cousin and the
rest of the the house stands no i know
but like at some point especially with
in-laws like yeah we all married into
each other but like we're not actually
related so
is this relationship worth keeping up
and like of course you try so hard for
your husband
i'm not speaking from personal
experience i'm just imagining because i
actually really like my in-laws not to
be annoying
but at some point it's like [ __ ] off
like why do i need this trouble let me
go hang with my own family you know
yeah so that's where i'm at but jackie's
advice is probably
more mature and better like when you
stop caring
you have all the power yeah exactly so
if she wants to be in this fight with
herself and be planning parties around
your parties like that's [ __ ] freaky
that's actually really good and
she'll try for something let her let her
keep fighting like herself
yeah like just let her keep like she'll
lose seem like punching the wall like
hoping someone punches back
yeah exactly that's good advice go with
jackie it's not mine my advice drive her
crazy
um and that is your toasters again if
you want to write in about
anything you're going through or you
want to give us an update about
something just if you want to like
actually drive her crazy you could like
say you're planning a party and then of
course she'll plan
a party following hers and then like
you'll say oh no i i cancelled mine
because you never actually planned and
she's like has all these parties that
yeah and then by the way you run up all
of her bills and then her house goes
into foreclosure she doesn't
plan parties anymore she gives me her
bills
yeah just keep like scheduling parties
and then canceling them like right
before but you never actually planned
to anyone but her right exactly be like
i'm thinking about having a party this
day at this time or at this location
we're gonna have fireworks
yeah you'll run her dry elephant like oh
yeah
petting zoo literally run her dry
like that's good advice um
all right again if you want to write in
for anything you're going through or you
have written to us and you want to give
us an update on how the
situation went dear toasters at
gmail.com and if you can't get enough
deer toasters we are recording a patreon
episode
full of deer toasters quandaries and
queries
so head over to patreon.com the morning
toast for
a whole podcast episode of your fellow
toasters
quandaries and queries thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast of
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the festive stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasts can be found so spotify itunes
republic video i already have walks of
all the places barbies and podcasts
foreign
hope you guys have an amazing hub day
we'll see you tomorrow bye